gerissene oder gesprungene smartphone
displays neben schwächelnden akkus wohl
das größte problem aller handy besitzer
und besitzerinnen die spider einer der
absolut beliebtesten appstore vielleicht
nicht mehr lange denn eine
forschungsgruppe aus japan hat eine
unglaubliche entdeckung gemacht ein
material für displays dass sich selbst
repariert wenn es gesprungen ist und
haltet euch fest um das hinzubekommen
müsste man demnach in zukunft nur noch
achtung handauflegen wie das genau
funktionieren soll und warum das nicht
nur für jeden smartphone besitzer ein
highlight wäre sondern auch für die
umwelt jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
ja fantastisch sensationell sich
wahnsinnig unglaublich unfasslich zehn
jahre clixoom wer hätte das gedacht
wir feiern dieses jahr mehr demnächst
manchmal sind ja die entdeckung die
durch zufall gemacht werden die besten
post sind zum beispiel eine solche
zufalls erfindungen auch in dieser fall
hier könnte so einer sein ein
forschungsteam aus tokio hatte nämlich
eigentlich nur das ziel einen neuen
klebstoff zu testen dabei herausgekommen
ist allerdings eine neuartige polymer
verbindung und die hat es in sich
polymere auch makromoleküle genannt sind
chemische verbindungen die aus vielen
gleichen oder ähnlichen grundbausteinen
den monomeren aufgebaut sind konkret
geht es in diesem fall um politikers ich
hoffe ich habe es richtig ausgesprochen
wie die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler das neuartige material
nennen es basiert also auf dem polymer
politiker an stoffen ist glas artig und
hart doch wenn die polymer verbindung
doch einmal splittern oder brechen
sollte ließe sich das wohl durch den
druck einer menschlichen hand reparieren
wie soll das bitte funktionieren es
handelt sich bei dem material um
sogenannte selbst heilendes material und
dies ist schon der erste baum moment
denn ihre polymer verbindung ist wohl
das erste selbst seine material
überhaupt dass sowohl eine hohe
mechanische stabilität als auch die
fähigkeit zur selbstheilung hat und das
bei raumtemperatur so schreiben es tabu
sei da und sein team von der universität
tokio und ihrer studie um risse wieder
zu schließen und sich selbst zu
reparieren brauchen die meisten der
bislang selbstheilende materialien sehr
hohe temperatur 120 grad celsius oder
mehr ein smartphone im backofen oder der
mikrowelle solch eine temperatur würde
andere komponenten des smartphones mit
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit zerstören und
in der mikrowelle passiert ja auch noch
vieles anderes das gibt ein nettes
feuerwerk anlass allerdings bei der neu
entdeckten polymer verbindung nach
angaben des japanischen forschungsteams
haften die geschnittenen kanten des
polymers zusammen wenn das material von
menschlicher hand bei etwa 21 grad
celsius zusammengepresst wird so bildet
es wieder eine feste oberfläche ohne
risse und sprünge und würde demnach nach
einigen
und sogar seine ursprüngliche stabilität
zurückgehalten
der japanische doktorand juliana gisa
war hat japanischen medien erzählt dass
er seine ergebnisse zuerst selbst
überhaupt nicht glauben konnte
bis er dann durch viele wiederholungen
seines experiments das sensationelle
ergebnis bestätigen konnte
jetzt ist yanagida war optimistisch dass
er mit dieser empfindung auch der umwelt
etwas gutes tun kann
zitat ich hoffe dass dieses
selbstheilende material nicht so schnell
weggeworfen wird wenn es einmal
zerbrochen ist nicht nur die smartphone
produktion und langlebigkeit könnte
diese erfindung revolutionieren sondern
auch die von anderen gadgets es ist
übrigens nicht das erste mal dass ein
polymer verbindung als selbst teilen des
materials smartphone displays
vorgeschlagen wird verschiedene
forschungsgruppen weltweit
experimentieren daran und tatsächlich
wurden auch bereits handys produziert
die in kleinem maßstab dazu in der lage
sind winzige kratzer von alleine wieder
zu schließen ja wenn ihr kein video zum
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier kein
abo aufs auge und vergessen dich den
genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr
auch immer über neue videos informiert
hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf
klicken die smartphones der zukunft
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleib dran